bonjour à vous mais des réacteurs avec
nous sur rt france pour que l'on
comprenne bien les maires de france ont
le sentiment d'être envoyé au casse-pipe
par le gouvernement sur cette question
du déconfinement ou des questions
principales elle reste le fait que
lorsque vous êtes à l'école lorsque
marchand et à l'école ce qu on entend
généralement c'est qu'il y ait depuis
peut-être 7h30 et 8h jusque parfois
18h30 19h et puis sur ce temps là il ya
une partie qui est assuré par les
enseignants et donc par l'éducation
nationale
et puis toute une partie qui était
assurée par des agents communaux la
pause méridienne les et de la garderie
après l'école etc et donc pendant ce
temps là c'est de ce sont généralement
des temps de générer de récréation où
les enfants sont dans la cour où il son
groupe mais en tout cas ils ne sont pas
dans une activité scolaire là où ils
sont assis et où là en effet le respect
de la distanciation physique et est
possible et relativement relativement
facile à obtenir
lorsque les enfants sortent de la classe
et bien évidemment ce sera extrêmement
des piscines de faire en sorte qu'ils
restent éloignés d'un mètres les uns des
autres et donc par conséquent cette
cette promiscuité si je puis dire des
enfants dans dans la cour par exemple de
demander ou dans les salles de classe
mme dans les salles d'activités et bien
fait craindre en effet au maire de
porter cette responsabilité pénale si
d'aventuré et bien l'épidémie reprenait
dans telle ou telle école où trouver sa
source dans telle ou telle école sur une
commune
c'est ça la question vous savez on a
déjà ses responsabilités pénales
lorsque par exemple des enfants donc on
des activités un peu brutale entre eux
ça peut arriver et il arrive que les
parents donc poursuivre à la fois les
animateurs et donc leur employeur de
maire parce que ceux ci n'ont pas fait
preuve selon eux de suffisamment de
précautions et suffisamment de
prévention envers les enfants donc c'est
ça qui nous inquiète énormément et
j'avais cru comprendre et nous avions
comprendre que les discussions que nous
avions avec le gouvernement permettrait
d'insérer dans le projet de loi
d'urgence dont vous avez parlé et qui
serait débattue à partir de demain au
parlement une disposition particulière
concernant cette responsabilité pénale
des mères j'ai cru comprendre que
malheureusement le gouvernement n'avait
pas choisi d'insérer cette disposition
dans le projet de loi donc nous verrons
ce qu'il en est maintenant au parlement
je sais que le sénat est extrêmement
attentif à cette question mais la
discussion parlementaire ne fait que
commencer à partir de demain nous
verrons ce qu'il ce qui est que ce qui
se dira mais en tout cas je crains que
si cette disposition d'allègement de la
responsabilité pénale encore une fois
pendant cette période bien particulière
n'est pas prise de nombreux maires
seront amenés à refuser la réouverture
de leur école cette disposition
concernant l'allègement justement la
responsabilité pénale des mères de quoi
s'agissait-il précisément ce n'est pas
encore un engagement du gouvernement
mais je sais que françois baroin le
président l'association des maires de
france est lui aussi monté au créneau il
réclame une protection juridique
supplémentaire pour les maires de france
oui c'est ça en fait cessé de modifier
donc les des textes actuels et de faire
en sorte que le maire ne puisse pas être
et ses agents les puisse pas être
poursuivi si malheureusement et d'
aventure donc des des cas de
transmission du virus étaient avérées
dans telle ou telle école c'est un
c'est vraiment du ressort de la
loi ça ne peut pas être une décision ni
du gouvernement tout seul ni des mers
naturellement ce n'est peut-être qu'une
qu'une disposition législative qui
modifient leurs pédales
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
finalement m'ont vu de notre côté on a
l'impression que le gouvernement les
élus locaux se renvoient un peu cette
patate chaude mais vous est-ce que vous
avez l'impression au niveau de votre
sentiment personnel que finalement le
gouv
à un moment il se dédouane dans la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire sur la
praye confinement pas écouter ceux des
douanes
je ne dirais pas cela et je dis nous
avons chacun et chacune des
responsabilités qui sont liées à notre à
notre fonction bon donc nous les
assurons moi lorsque j'ai souhaité donc
prendre une disposition qui oblige au
corps d'une protection de la gauche est
donnée dans ma commune l'état ma liste
et pas à vous de le faire c'est pas
votre pied pas votre boulot le conseil
d'état a donc retoqué m'ont arrêté bon
très bien ça veut dire que en réalité il
est lié par la mer la responsabilité que
je pouvais avoir en tant que maire au
titre du code des collectivités
territoriales en matière de salubrité
publique
il a balayé sa 11è d'étape on est donc
maintenant quand il s'agit d'exécuter
une forme de décision qui a été prise
finalement par le gouvernement et par le
président de la république à savoir
réouvrir les écoles à partir du 11 mai
maintenant on décentralise oui on
décentralise essentiellement l'exécution
tout en sachant que cette exécution peut
faire courir un risque pénal au maire
donc c'est quand même une attitude qui
est assez particulière et qui n'est pas
très respectueuse des uns et des autres
des différents acteurs nous ne nous
avons un travail considérable pour
mettre en place ce serait cette
réouverture des écoles à travail que
nous faisons en partenariat avec les
fonctionnaires de l'éducation nationale
qui sont par deux communes ça se passe
bien en général connais bien ces
fonctionnaires l'accent sur le terrain
mais par ailleurs nous avons le
sentiment qu'en effet au niveau national
eh bien les préoccupations que nous
exprimons et même parfois les avis que
nous pourrions exprimées ne sont pas
pris en compte non pas au niveau local
mais au niveau des décisions général des
décisions nationales
c'est ce que j'appelle décentralisation
d'exécution mais savait pas une
décentralisation de codécision avec le
pouvoir central
ça n'est pas nouveau je constate qu'à
l'occasion de cette crise est bien la
situation ne s'améliore pas merci à
beaucoup philippe laurent rappelle que
vous êtes neruda
sow et secrétaire de l'association des
maires de france merci à vous